do you like scary movies hey wait don't
run away we just wanted to let you know
that scream 6 is coming out soon and
give you the must-know details about it
you're not scared are ya the first three
scream installments came out in pretty
rapid succession in 1996 1997 and 2000
it would be 11 years before Scream 4 hit
theaters in 2011 though there was
another 11-year break before the fifth
film simply titled scream hit in January
2022. oh my God he's making a recall a
what it's a sequel that also serves as a
reboot introducing new characters
alongside established vets the result
was one of the very best movies of 2022.
basically guaranteeing a new entry in
the series fortunately for scream fans
the movies are back to a Rapid Release
clip according to Bloody Disgusting
Scream 6 originally had a release date
of March 31st 2023 but Paramount
Pictures actually moved it up to March
10th Paramount likely moved the date
because the studio has another big
release scheduled for the 31st Dungeons
and Dragons honor among Thieves there
are lots of other competing releases
throughout March including Creed 3 John
Wick chapter 4 and Shazam Fury of the
Gods so it'll be interesting to see if
screams 6 can slice and dice its way to
the top of the box office rankings
the official trailer for Scream 6
promises something far more intense than
we've seen in the series so far it kicks
off with two of the protagonists from
2022's Scream Sam and Tara Carpenter
Desperately Seeking shelter in a New
York Bodega but that won't stop
Ghostface who gets his hands on a
shotgun and begins to hunt Our Heroes
down we then jump back to slightly less
scary times as Sam tells us I had this
Secret
there's a Darkness inside of me Sam is
no doubt referencing the Specter of her
dad Billy Loomis one of the original
Ghost Face Killers together Sam and the
other survivors from the previous film
plot to execute the new ghost face but
this villain seems considerably more
violent than any version we've seen
before the trailer offers a glimpse of a
ghostface Shrine and a collection of
ghost-faced statues each one seemingly
representing the film series previous
baddies it also highlights what's bound
to be one of the creepiest moments of
the movie our heroes are trapped on a
subway filled with costumed
trick-or-treaters as a ghost face figure
slowly but surely makes its way towards
Mindy Meeks Martin it's pretty clear
he's not looking for candy the 2022
scream actually had a good number of
survivors Tara and Sam Carpenter Mindy
and Chad Meeks Martin and the pistol
packing Gail weathers all made it
through to the end original final girl
Sydney Prescott also survived though she
won't be returning in screamed six the
new installment is moving from Woodsboro
to New York as the surviving heroes from
the fifth film look to escape their
bloody past and find a new start but
like Jason Voorhees once did Ghostface
is taking Manhattan Tara Sam Mindy and
Chad will have to join forces with
Intrepid reporter Gail if they're going
to make it out alive star Jenna Ortega
who plays Tara told Entertainment
Tonight Ghostface gets a lot more
intimidating it just gets more and more
gory I think that this is probably the
most aggressive and violent version of
Ghostface we've ever seen Melissa
Barrera who plays Sam backed this up
telling collider with the last scream
directors Matt bettinelli open and Tyler
Gillette were tiptoeing and trying to be
very respectful of what the franchise
had been up until that point and keeping
their inner gory dreams at Bay but with
this one they were like we're going all
out it's potentially a hundred times
gorrier
there are two Mainstays of the scream
franchise Ghostface and Sydney Prescott
but as we mentioned Scream 6 is the
first installment of the series in which
Sydney won't be appearing actress Nev
Campbell who plays Sydney told people
that the paycheck she was being offered
for the film was insulting she said I
did not feel that what I was being
offered equated to the value that I
bring to this franchise and have brought
to this franchise for 25 years I
honestly don't believe that if I were a
man and had done five installments of a
huge Blockbuster franchise over 25 years
that the number that I was offered would
be the number that would be offered
another original cast member Courtney
Cox will be back in Action as Gail
weathers she'll be joined by another vet
from the franchise Hayden Panettiere her
character Kirby Reed who was introduced
and seemingly killed and screamed for
evidently survived her Stab Wound
they'll also be joined by screen 2022
Stars Jenna Ortega Jasmine Savoy Brown
Melissa Barrera and Mason Gooding plenty
of newcomers are on board for the sixth
installment too Tony revolori from the
MCU Spider-Man films and the babysitter
Stars Samara weaving will have roles
they'll be joined by Henry zurny Dermot
mulrooney Jack Champion Leanna liberato
Devin nakota and Josh segarra and while
we don't know who's wearing the ghost
face mask we know who will provide that
chilling voice as always Roger L Jackson
but there's never been one like me
the 2022 scream was a hit with critics
and at the box office so there's no
reason to mess around with that formula
that's why Matt bettinelli open and
Tyler Gillette have returned to direct
Scream 6 along with producer Chad
valella the trio is known collectively
as radio silence in addition to 2022's
scream they've honed their horror chops
on the Anthology horrorflix southbound
the 103198 segment of the original VHS
and the hilarious demonic Thriller Ready
or Not which starred Samara weaving
speaking with nme Gillette explained to
the directing Duo's goals for the new
flick saying part of our assignment on
Scream 5 was to play The Greatest Hits
to really show that we were part of a
long lineage of characters with Scream 6
we wanted to subvert that warm blanket
and make something that's grittier and
rarer it's Relentless and really
visceral
screenwriters James Vanderbilt and Guy
Busick collaborated to help revive the
franchise with the 2022 scream and now
they're teaming up again for scream 6.
Busick has worked with radio silence
before co-writing the script for ready
or not he's also contributed to TV shows
such as Castle Rock and stand against
evil as for Vanderbilt he's got an
Eclectic set of credits including the
Amazing Spider-Man Independence Day
Resurgence murder mystery and David
Fincher zodiac on the producing side of
things radio silences Chad valella will
serve as an executive producer alongside
many others including Courtney Cox and
Kevin Williamson who penned the scripts
for the original scream and scream 2.
[Music]